good morning to all my name is
cardinal morelia I am a technician and another
drummer from the University of Buenos
Aires and today I am going to present a talk
on ecology in handling rats and
mice
you will know these two species are
the most used the most chosen
as  the investigation so there is a lot of
information and in an hour we are going to try
to provide concepts and things that would be
important there is a lot a lot of information
that the most important thing we are going to treat you
with that of this presentation for a
strawberry
let's start at the beginning then the
glasses and portions  laboratory are
different species but have a
common origin both are class
mammals or hearing and france-
units
as we see the bands and mice
followed until different have a
common ancestor I 10 15
million years ago when a
break between you and traits
we send you because the back gowns are
the most chosen those have several
qualities that co  They contribute to their
popularity as research models,
the two species are very
well characterized, there is a lot of
information and biography about them,
that is, we know them well in their
biology, their genetics, their needs, etc.
The buttons are the micro model system,
scientific research, they
were the first.  Mammals after
the bad ones that had this entrusted their
genome turning out to have many
similarities with the others
this has greatly favored the studies of
genetics of course basic genetics of
mammals and has allowed to study
particular functions of
specific hygiene within the world of the
conscious book and has  Of course,
Díaz mice are the ideal model
for the study of many of the
properties that affect humans and
also other animals.
Rats also have their uses
in their qualities, they are good for
rearing and behaviors,
mainly.  in because they are very
docile t  They have great ability to
act in new environments their
tendency to explore is also very
good and their own idea of ​​learning
when they are trained also the fruits
have a lot of response capacity
for punishment reward tests and we
tell you the sensory ones the mice and
well too  They are used for
behavioral studies, those are not so
expert to run mazes, for example,
and they are used more in
behavioral studies, for studies
focused especially on
research with pheromones,
some more characteristics
regarding that it has a great
reproductive capacity and this benefits us, it tolerates
well, inbreeding, things that other
species do not do, then this
gives us the possibility of having
almost identical animals that are intercompatible with
each other but without reaching
selections, which is quite useless, for example,
for studies in which the variables
are not somewhat  blocked or for studies
in the princes and is just  ment this
with photos this compatibility for
example for many people take our
skin foreheads and other types of studies
also our that we have
inbreeding and that they have a great
reproductive capacity so we
have a large number of pipes available and
this as very good ways  for
research and very useful they
have a short gestation period
which means they can produce
multiple generations for
monitoring multimedia signals with
studies in a relatively short time
per mouse for example can produce
some or less four generations per
year in good conditions
but otherwise  and rats and mice
are also acts to be raised
using special techniques
as animals and free of
specific pathogenic germs as animals
will be cold which allows us to then
have the same lesion at a high
sanitary quality and also then in this
way reduce or eliminate variables one
density in our t  Lastly, the
research work
is the great reproductive capacity.
Songs will also
benefit us in terms of costs. It is
much more economical to produce
small-sized animals that have
a great reproductive capacity than
compared to the animal in New York,
Paul who does not want to.  enriched
cheap very expensive to keep it
that they raise animals simple
equipment they need cars and
things but compared to other
species it is cheap
as we see rodents have many
similarities with other mammals their
body is made up of the same
system for example digestive
system respiratory system urinary system
lymphatic system or circulatory system
and at the same time they are distributed within the
organism in the same way and their
composition, that is, the organs that
make up each system, are also
similar to those of us,
so in each cell each part of
a cell also turned out to be consumed
in distributions.  bution composition and
functioning in other mammals among
other mammals and the values
well some more characteristics
jan bratoz oratory both
are omnivorous
we although in the vivarium we leave
some specific balanced diets those
for example it is normal that they eat for
example the placentas of their pups or not
Sometimes when we see cases of
cannibalism in the animal room, they also
tend to take the films of other
animals.
Remember that the results at the bar can
be eaten by summer insect eggs
or even other animals and possibly
the nerve 3 would also eat it and
they both offered it to us.  row 2 and the mice
are sorry test and this means that
only a series of teeth grows
that are permanent for life they
have two
upper incisors the lower incisors and three pairs of
upper molars of interest lower
16 teeth
the molars once formed  They don't grow
anymore and they wear out progressively
over time.  go of life that is to say that they are
arms 2010
and they are separated from the incisors by
this space that we see in the
oral cavity that is called via external
the incisors on their side are and there are three
and that means that once formed they
will continue to grow continuously  throughout
life the normal growth cap of
these teeth is equal to the rate of
wear so that the targets
maintain a constant size in
adults and it is estimated that
a complete replacement of listeners occurs every 35
45 lifetimes
the branches and the  mice both just
like rabbits as presented in the
rabbit biology talk are
prone to have a problem of
malocclusion which is the
continuous growth of teeth which creates the
problem that animals sometimes happen that
the lower incisor teeth
dig in  In the upper stage, the
upper aspects are stuck in the tongue and
in this way the water is obstructed that
the animals cannot eat. This
problem is at hand.  Associated with punta factories,
among them, it has been associated, for example, with
the hardness of the pellets, which are
not hard enough for the
animal to wear down its teeth, but
there is also some genetic factor because
there are many, there are many studies that
show that different mushrooms have
different incidence.  In Tolima, they demanded
inclusion.
Well, since we have here devastating
victims of these teeth, I will tell you the
case that the enamel that covers the
teeth has an
iron pigment and that is why they have that characteristic color, they
appear working
and in the ethical system we exist from the
animals of both rats and mice that
are similar digestive tract and
other mammals esophagus stomach duodenum
61 and have been by everton and the
canes have the particularity that they
have a gallbladder which is the photo
that we can see in the small river and the
rats do not  they have
a gallbladder a particularity that they have and in the
matter of management of rats and
rats  ones both in this case you are a
picture of rats but the mice are the
same is that they have large children
so they can measure a
third of the total digestive tract
the cecum produces a fermentation
through which bacteria act on
fibers  or other materials from the
small intestine that could not be digested,
such as cellulose or thymine
from vegetables and services or
rifles or jetta, then these products
that are so difficult to digest are not
ingested in the small tube due to this
fermentation that occurs  and saying
in heaven they
celebrate and produce products that are
metabolically useful for animals
including short chain fatty acids
vitamin k and also the complex
of short chain tract elements
are then absorbed in the colon and the
vitamins are partly absorbed and  in
parts they are discarded by the
fecal matter and for this reason the animals later
both the rats and the connections in
e  The habit of coprophagy so that it
deals with people from churches in
behavior because if they are housed,
for example, on floors or bars and they
cannot perform the habit of
coprophagy then they are losing
these vitamins that are important for
the sun
well with respect to  thermoregulation
the animals more in a little bit and today I want
thermos and the first week they do not have
thermoregulation mechanisms but after a
week of age in sar they are
homeotherms and they acquire
thermoregulation mechanisms that help them
adapt to climate changes
and that is what our exercise has
wide body in proportion to you today this
makes them quite sensitive to
changes and temperatures so
there is an environmental temperature range
called somenson alterman australes
within which an animal can maintain
its metabolic balance without effort
for rats and mice in that thermo zone
neutral is different for mice is
between 26 and 34 degrees and e  In the Kampala area,
we have neutral rats. There are some
author discrepancies. As an
average, we will take between 26 and 29
degrees.
Mice are especially sensitive
to low temperatures. I
like hot environments better, and rats, on
the contrary, prefer environments more.
cool than the hot ones and
this base is difficult for them in hot environments
neither of these two species
have sweat glands
distributed everywhere and as a task as
if man has then they do not sweat and
do not have that mechanism for
regulating their temperature  body is
then when the animals are
exposed to environmental temperatures that
were outside those ranges of their
neutral subject zone, they become stressed and
the
behavioral and physiological thermoregulation mechanisms are activated to
ensure that their body loses and conserves
heat according to its needs when these
behavioral mechanisms are activated.  address
these resources that those have  they have
thermoregulation mechanisms
some of their biological functions are exhausted they
can be compromised for
example gurus are their immune system of their
growth
the tail is a very important organ
in both gowns and mice in
mice and they have a
thermoregulatory function between the tendons  That
run inside the tail run
friendly vessels and the knowers can
regulate their body temperature
by dilating or constricting
especially the veins of the folds
when the undersides are dilated
blood flows through the tail and comes into
contact with the outer surface
then heat is released
the one who fears under
passes the animation with the
inverter system and when the rodent needs to
retain heat in its body
then everything is under constriction to
restrict the flow of blood the tail
already feels the loss of heat
the school also has  function as
to help the body in balance the menu
its balance balance  or
even if we approach when we
finish a twig but we
visualize a finger to the tail of the
mouse the mouse will like it or to
perch and it will wrap our finger with
its tail
good in cats and mice
interact with the environment
through  of their lives or mustaches that are
special hairs that function as
tactile receptors and are distributed
throughout different parts of the body but
mainly as we see in the photos
in some little arrows so that they have them
better on the head in the cervical region
and on the face
these hairs  They are different and function
morphologically and functionally those
that make up their fur, so
surely they will also be able to observe these, it
is very rich in mice, for example,
like Haussler mice,
the rodents that use the little books
then to explore for missing things
about donuts and to detect possible
dangers with contacts and also
as tactile contact as with other
animals rats  s and mice communicate at
ultrasound frequencies and this
means that they could be disturbed
by stable ultrasound in those present in
a vivarium or in a laboratory that
are not audible, for example those emitted
by computers or
fluorescent lights or by
ventilation equipment or with  cell
phones even though they are inside
elections animals also tend to
startle when
non-visual noises are produced good environment group
regarding the choice
both rats and mice especially those
that are albino more than pigmented
but all in general but albino controls
have poor visual acuity  but to
compensate for this they have a
very wide visual field and they are very susceptible and very
skilled at detecting movements
within this visual field they are very attentive and
between them detecting food both
species are microchromatic which
means that they have only two types of
cells that all the  bicolor in the
retina that are one cell  Now more with what
they also talked about in another
talk at the bio conference and that is why they
have a little less perception of
colors than the man who has a
non-chromatic vision, that is to say, with three
types of cells with their clothes,
yes, I am
very good.  both species have yang the
harder jana that lie behind
the eye socket porphyrins are secreted
the shades normally control the
amount of light reaching the
blacks and provide photoprotection to
the list
normally not seen but sometimes more so
in rats than in rats  Mice can be
notorious and reddish spots can be read
around the eyes around the
nostrils as we open in the
legs because they do want to
sanitize and their mental sideburns get stained
sometimes they are confused with these they call them
red tears they confuse them with blood
for us we know if they are like this we are
in the presence of when in the
presence of porphyrins what you have to
do is take a mu  estra and take it
under the ultraviolet cross because the
finally to that fluorescent environment under
ultraviolet light and blood not in
general the appearance of curtains is
associated with the issue of stress
well a little to compensate for their poor
eyesight they have the new senses
the  sense of smell and highly developed head people
use it to get
food to detect nightstands
and their signal these factories represent
a very important behavior in their
social and family life stefan for
example when mothers just suffered they
have followed the marks with pheromones
then  That is why it is always said that
when you breed them when there is
a newly native female, it is
convenient not to change them on this day.
mother have time to recognize improve
the pups and it is also said that when
the mother in the wall for her pups if
she cam  bia the cage is preferable, in addition
to passing the young, it will pass a little of the
shavings or a little of the fearsome people of the
enrichment to the nest that we have
put in it in order to also pass those
colors that are going to make the female
kill as relatives north relatives
that  link that it has with its activity is
good to take into account we have
some effects described in mice that
are produced by pheromones so we
have to take them into account to
use them to our benefit or sometimes
so that they do not harm us when we
arm the apparitions for a long
time  It is known that, for example, when
four or more females are housed in the
absence of males, their life cycles
become irregular, it slows down and
eventually stops, and this phenomenon is
known as sector and butt or extension
of the strange cycle,
and then that this  group of mbas we
expose a male or more precisely
to the smell of his urine
their sexual cycles are synchronized
again
their sites  s of stress but it does not start
again it restarts and also tends to
synchronize and this phenomenon would be the
name of the witten effect or
synchronization of the celio
other phenomena caused by
pheromones
is the effect or bruce or the introduction of
the seasons when a female
missed by  one by one
by a male and after a few days of
gestation it is exposed to another male or
in the ordes hill or this contact with
the smell of his urine was admitted,
what is called interruption
of pregnancy occurs or an abortion was defeated  in
the seasons prematurely
this effect is called the blues effect
and another aspect is the van der vaart which
is also called the early door
which consists of the acceleration of the
start of the school of puberty of
the cells induced by the mere
presence of the  talk about the males
that is why it is important sometimes to
enjoy them animalize on time with
all the reasons we do not let them spend a lot of
time with the others because it can  n
getting to have surprises
we are going to see improvise a bit the
behavior that is so that the rats
and mice currently used in
comparison with their wild relatives
have slower movements are
fatter and luckily they are quite
domesticated are less aggressive and much
more friendly to  handling
are nocturnal animals and normally
carry out their most important activities
at night, for example, they mate,
fight, play, stallions build nests
for the young, that is why we will
generally detect early births.
Dead
we are going to detect it early in the
morning during the day, it would be because they are
most of their behavior, they do it
at night, they are species like tactics,
both of them, that is to say, that full of routes
always run along the periphery
on vertical surfaces,
if we  we release a mouse in an
open space
the rare animal  mind will cross the
resistant to the enclosure diagonally because
it lasts for these open spaces
are social animals that nature
favorable environmental conditions
form stable families that are
known as others and that are
made up of all up to 100
members as dominance hierarchies
in  both sexes males and females
families mark their territory which
is felt by both by male and
female against animation of other
groups in general by interbreeding between
groups
the construction of nests that the
running of material towards the nest is an
associative behavior  which is
considered an act in the mouse and
learned in the case of the ramps both
the males and the cells use
this behavior in their
natural habitat and in captivity they also
use it if they are given the opportunity
to better adapt perhaps to
climatic situations of the  environment
lamata fernando finally it is the
females that are interested  They are not the
females and males as females
and especially the females that are
pregnant and the tenderness
that is why it is said that the plants to
take more advantage of the enrichment in the
nest as environmental enrichment if
it is given to us at an early age so that
the  vast can in front of a taurus
and take advantage of the best both species
spend much of their time
grooming themselves and other
individuals individual grooming
consists of performing a thorough self-
cleaning of the entire body
following a sequence of
specific steps if  There are no more two
variations, that is to say that the animals,
rats and mice have a
standard operating procedure for their
personal hygiene
and self-grooming, on the other hand,
social grooming is more localized, it
is different and it is considered an
affiliative social interaction that is of
benefit to  all those who participate
in it
in this social rapprochement in general
participate two  mice but sometimes they
can participate more and the record to
tone the other using its
old legs and its mouth for the
most times it also uses its teeth to
clean the hair from the base pulling
the scalp upwards
cleaning the point well
Unlike self-grooming,
social grooming is not such an
exhaustive
cleaning, but rather a localized cleaning between
the nape area, passing through
the shoulder area and up to the middle of
the companion's dome, generally the animal that
is  being this way, also very
graphic, the side may be paying
attention to other things that look
around them, even sometimes they are seen
walking while the other partner
continues trying to groom them
well, also when they see
behaviors that are not beneficial in our vivarium at times
nor did they
explain our research work with them,
we are going to see the most
common ones as if ours were
a more common one.  Unknown to many is
the bar behring, which is an
abnormal compulsive behavior that has been observed
in animals and mice, but that is more
frequent in mice and especially in
certain strains, for example, in the 357
bases for part 57, the normal is
further back as well.  It is seen and I also tell
you in particular in exo
bred mice what I have seen is quite different
that it is volume because in the bar billing
an animal and it directly tears others
to another animal or it has been a club sometimes
the whiskers mobilized hyper the
specific regions  of the body
sometimes even causing
dermatitis or initiatives or other
types of injuries depending on the
strain and the reaction between the
participating lines this interaction has
different patterns new grimes here
we can see some of the photos the
first are animals coming out of  animals
in the group hauser and the last one we
see that the crochet removes the photos
but if you
are an animal it is a  The boy is a cub and
the mother has said something to him, the whole wolf has been withdrawn from him,
well, another unwanted behavior is
the fights that are seen especially in
sore males.
some fights
will generally end when
some of the animals get
hurt but sometimes the degree of
aggression can be very high and the fight
ends with the death of one of
the animals.
That will occur more
frequently when the animals are not seen
enough space and they are
formed in cages, they are group cages
but with compatible social groups.
Well, another thing that we can
normally find inside is
stereotyped behaviors of acid
types that are repetitive accesses without
variation.  and without any apparent objective
there are many patterns, for example, of giving
vu  eltas from the moore cage from the
clubs jump into the corner and
well these are very common operations
in animals that, for example, are
not provided with environmental enrichment or
animals that are very, very stressed when
one of these endless things appears is
enough  difficult to reverse and with more
than one providing them with
environmental growth once it appeared we can
minimize the fights a bit with a
minimum of the barbie we can minimize the
stereotype that they will not disappear
so the best thing is always
prevention before we have these
problems  we plan the
environmental enrichment according to each
experience
each species has its preferences
studies have been carried out that tell us both
in a thousand mangoes in rats and mice first of
all the best thing is always the
interaction with their fellow
species
then the housing of cages in
group cages  I have always preferred
lodging in an individual cage before
but they always talk  do of compatible social groups
in the case of the mouse those of the
most valued worlds this time material
for children some complexity in the
cages for example that the floor where
I do everything at the same height if you can not
put things so that they have different
heights and provide them resolution  In the
case of the rats, brutal cages,
first, a certain complexity in the cage,
shelters, and finally, material for
children who remember that when there is heat, at
the same time, the drama so that they learn to
use them
in terms of using interaction with the
animal hand as the method.  of application
animal training really in these
certainties for larger species you
can plan more in an interaction
interaction or games for example a
dog is used as an
animal enrichment method but
in laboratory animals such as rats
and mice it is quite difficult although
my  impossibility what we have to
keep in mind is that mice are
a bit more
surly societal  ales and they are not so happy
with the rats that they do show a
predisposition it even seems that they
like contact with people
but they can always
have a beneficial seat when handling animals
to see the species the
mice are going to build now
handle  and well to react better
when touching them and manipulating the
experimental lighting and well in
rats with rats they love it
directly if we plan for
environmental aging
in print we lose human
animals as part of a
nominal growth program we have to take into
account that this  this routine and that
planned routine and it must have
continuity if we are going to have the time
to define the program we
continue then it is better
directly announcing what is most
recommended in my opinion to achieve
human-animal interaction with these
species is at the time of change  from the
fact take the animals 1 carbon
then one v  to have instead of making
the change of animals but here the
rapids rapids take your time and
make time for the
animals handle them and get
used to the contact with the
shoulders
good some physiological parameters
in rats for example the expectation of
end of life
under normal conditions, always
keep in mind that we are going to have
variations between different strains of
animals or animals that, for example,
are sick, we are talking about
normal parameters, the animal in a certain
health and the life expectancy of
brave rats in sign creeds  and three
and a half years the weight of the animals at the most
35 grams after weaning are between
40 and 50 grams and the weight of the
adult male will reach 520
grams their body temperature is from 35
9 to 35 37 5 the rectal
temperature is  degrees Celsius
consume between 10 and 12 milliliters of
water for every 100 grams of it their
body weight per day and consume between  e 5 and 6
grams of balanced food for every
100 grams of her body weight per
olivia also indicated here the frequency
change of base against respiratory in
case someone is useful the
data regarding the reasons
life expectancy is between two and three years  at birth they
weigh one gram and their adult weight
can reach up to 40 grams
although I write in the most
commonly used strains they weigh between 25 and
30 grams the body temperature is
between 30 and 65 and 38 degrees Celsius the
water consumption is 15 milliliters per
every 100 grams of your weight with play of
per day and food between 12 and 18
grams per 100 grams of your
body weight to four lines also 6
with the parameters of
respiratory rate and heart rate
because someone at 60
we are going to see a  little how to make of the
physical roses of these animals in
similes in rats and mice in some
respects the rats that mature in a
day before the mice but are
similar in the  day but here we see from
the photo that garlic are born without hair with their
eyes closed and have
the pinnae of the ears folded over the
auditory canal on the head the day they
are born we see a strong red color
and after 24 hours the color  It's going to
be a paler pink color, it's
translucent so we can control
if it contains milk and if they're
feeding well, too, although they don't
like it with the photo
in the navel area, very little straight
from what the umbilical cord was
in  this is an edged photo for moving the
figures of the umbilical balloon
and well easy between day 2 and day 3
we will see that the skin
thickens although the stomach contents can still be seen
and
the pigment begins to appear little by little  from the fur
of colored animals
the pinnae already at their
edges begin to be expected a little from
the head earlier in
faults than in mice
around the fifth and sixth day the fur
is  The
colored animals are completely pigmented and
a fluff begins to grow that shows the
color of the fur.
the gum can
be the incisors teeth through
transparent pores because the skin of the
lancia also enters without obesity it is not
because they have already made a solution just
offensive solution that occurs
around day 9 or 10 of life in 9 in
the new mice the trans bands and  10
in the bullies and the movements
then they begin to eat balanced meals little by little
at this point
also as you can see in these photos in the
two species they have their
earphones deployed and in a
vertical position earlier always the
rat than the mouse and they will have  In addition to the
hair covered with hair, short hair and in
the females,
the mother will be seen
on the 10th between 10 and  15 arriving
the opening of the eyes begins those
first as they take the photos they open
their eyes a little as if they were
spying
then we will give an oval shape and
finally they will take that
characteristic well rounded shape a couple of
days later like those who  We are going to see
in the existing
animals the animals at 22 days of age are
independent of the mother and are already
ready for electric some pepas
require hayfields is to have a little
some give them a few more days before
decreeing the but general of the
district lied  ordinas at four or
five weeks, the door force generally occurs
and a week after
approximately the initials to
the two methods begin from the first day of
the series, it is considered that it has
fully matured and some reproductive characteristics that are not ready to be
turned off.
They are going to help us to manage
our colonies and sexual maturity,
we already said between 7 and 10 grade systems
They are more seasonal, that is to
say that their estrous cycle is repeated
continuously throughout the year, the
estrous cycle lasts between four and five
days and they have a postpartum heat
approximately 12 hours after
the female appears austerity. They have a
yellow post-vaginal touch that later  We are
going to see him and his gestation is an average
of 21 days, sometimes he recommended that
mice be inside cans, but
average lives are small for him,
there is more than one grid for each
gestation,
rats a little more than mice
and rats  they have six pairs of breasts
and cats are five for that man 2 the
useful reproductive life of these animals
in both in both syntheses is
approximately between 17 and 8 months and 8
months where we can have
approximately 16 chambers
well let's see a little about the
maintenance of the colonies according to the
genetic profile we can obtain from the
rarest in broad strokes two types of
colonies the colonies exo
bred men who  e are colonies of
whole animals and boots and are maintained through
rigorous crossbreeding systems
programmed especially for them the
crossbreeding of related animals and
thus avoid company age
the correct way to name these
animals is first putting
the laboratory code in this case is rl  It is in
fact a colon above and the name of
the zeta, which in this case is in the android writer.
Well, the other genetic profile that
we have are the strains in two bred today
and that are made up of animals, volumes
and others, each of these lines in the
prismas comes from a single pair of
parents using the offensive tendency
stopping for at least 20 more generations
directly brother by sister this
reproductive scheme increases the degree of
motivation and they have
genetically identical animals that is 12 monkeys
what is sought as a
genetic profile in  these lines
and with respect to the nomenclature we are
going to give you better this the following but
to v  Sometimes you can see that in addition to the name
we see that there is an estimate one with a
number and that refers to the generation
that corresponds to the animal and this
helps us to simply see indicate the degree
of impediment that this animal has
is not part of life  hard official if
you are used
with good as are the names of these
tits of rats and mice being raised
according to the average height with a
short series to see if that is the case with a
short series of capital letters being able to
have a number
but it will always go in  First of all, the
capital letter, what happens with the waltz and
with the 129 in front of it, it has a lower
case letter and the strain cento de inmates
that starts with a good number, these
are zetas that historically had already
been named before
we started with this of the  nomenclature and
then it is known, you are well
known, the historical name
of it was maintained,
what happened when you told each other that the
great one, the name of the accepted, there is a
bar, well, yes  It means that we are
in the presence of its strains, so
first in darker letters
we have the original sev and
then we will have the code of the
laboratory to which the neuron belongs
supposedly in theory the amount of
near is that one buys an animal and
where  There will be another animal house
supposedly in theory there are infinite
possibilities to continue putting together your
dinners so they are, for example, you could
buy the 657
vélez barras 6 j and if you see later
that it has something else it is because they are
banknotes from Armenia epa and I put
carolina morelia cn and  in like the code
below from my
lab sometimes they wander on purpose sometimes they
build because our games are made
that are in a lab we want
an active forming a facet
what happened to the balance the balance has
an hour mark but it doesn't have any
code below then the
balance that many things are forgiven
because it is a very important animal in animal
science  al in the laboratory is allowed
to have is to do that it actually
represents a recessive gene that
has varicose veins
so let's be very careful about the
nomenclature especially with the strains
reasons because there are many exceptions
good for the maintenance of these
lines with blood it is recommended  a
system based on a founding nucleus and
one or more of its own expansion is the
founding nucleus is the most valuable thing
we have and we have to take care of it because
our source of animals q2 and
denounced then rigorous
endangerment records and being genetically very
controlled
and the nuclei of  expansion what comes out
of the expansion nuclei is what we are
going to give the researchers to
work with what we are going to train
there can be no cross-circulation as
we say of the vivarium always the
reproductive couples of the health of the
founding nucleus and we will never take
extracting animals and putting them into the
good founding nucleus is important sometimes before  It is
to say that it is going to say well I want to
put myself and raise more a
large production of foreign animals if it is really
necessary because to produce
laboratory animals even the rats of the expense
I do not know I really want a lot of time
many are a lot of money and many
commitments for that reason yes in reality
We have a client, the experimentation guys,
we think first if it is
not convenient for us, I have bought the animals
directly from a benchmark producer
and who have
experience in the partner.
the test a figure that
in the reference animal house they do not
have it and well planted in first it
descended previous reference if they can
make an agreement so that
the animals occur and good end if
we are not left behind and we cannot take advantage of
the experience of the bio bio the  producer
or if we ourselves have
started with an important cause
the first thing he does then
plan  Before bringing you sometime,
we have different types of walls,
we have permanent periods and
the temporary ones appear. Permanent rigs
are those in which the
animals spend their whole lives together. They have the
advantages, for example, that the cage does not have to
be modified.  They put together and always create the
same thing, that crazy
esparto grass is used,
the maxi, the female, we comply, we separate,
this zeal is used, that is to say, the
productivity and the female built to
make more gold is less interesting, it is less
intensive for the male and it is easy to
keep records because it does not  I speak so much
movement of animals it is easier
the records go away
the advantages that they can have is that
many cages are needed that
more males are needed compared to other
systems that sometimes there are issues in
which the male is aggressive and there may
be problems of  cannibalism towards the
young and if one dies and both are discarded
and well also the points but
there are also sales to that if bi
for the male it is less intensive for the
female it is more intensive because the
projection is shared by the female and it is
fine since the lines of new wind
that we are sending are gestating and it is
very intensive for her this system
to take the cages we can do
at  I command monogamous systems and a male
and a female forming trios of 22 females
with one male in this case, the two
females always remain together with the
male, but he is not paid in
adem systems in which we have three
or more cells with  what the male does
what is done is when the
female first removes it so that she
has the cold in another cage and
then returns it to the cage of a tame
male
this that we saw here is an example of a
system  polygamous, which is a temporary system
in which we have
producing females and we have the one in the middle in
color on the wild bar we see the
cages of the males and a
rotation scheme is made for those carrying the
female  towards the cage of a manches
where the first one took from
inside the breeding stock
and offered them to the male we left them
mated for a certain period of
time
and then he went to the maternity to the
maternity area where their
young stand and are raised  until weaning and
then when the zebra is when
the pups are congratulated the females
will return to par with this when it is
housed in the females the rest we put
reproductive units
in general they are left to rest for a
while and then they are returned to  Variables
This system, if we need a
very large production, is continuously
in motion,
then these temporary rigs like
this example that we have just seen, which are
animals that are separated after the
cardboard, have some advantages and
some disadvantages, among the advantages
that we are going to need less amount of
males month more or less amount of cage
without moving some are replaced by others
in trouble there is less prob  cannibalism abilities
because the female is going to
comfort the calm young and their
cages and the requests
of the animals are better scheduled because with this type of
various modules as we have dates
mating programs we are also going to
have the dates scheduled for the
mysteries in the  everyone knows them you are a
little more difficult to program in some
disadvantages that these temporary agreements have
is that this crazy expert is not taken advantage of
that we are going to have
therefore less litter by the
female in the charm less productivity
is more inclusive for the  macho, I don't know if it
's an advantage or if a macho will
take advantage of it, the records are going to be more
complicated
and we have to have a lot of
responsibility and expertise from the
technicians to make the
thoughts accordingly and to keep these
records that are a little more
completely
good for them.  I had commented on the
marginal plug the big one and mouse that is a
mixture of selections of those of sexual friends of
d  e male olives and
glands interventions of the vagina of
the female that coagulates in the vagina of the
alhambra and that then they can
indicate that the plug had appeared
will indicate that a guapa although it does not
necessarily indicate that the previous sample
in the  mice in the heel that lasts between
8 and 12 hours inside the vagina,
which makes it easier to detect it the day
after having made the wall and in
the case of the rat there are a few hours
left but since there is less time left in general
what is  It does when you want to detect
morning tampa is to place the couple on a
grate floor without shavings in the
tray below then the following two days
it goes through the final shape
and looks for it in the tray or in the
registered
well both the cover  morning helps us
to know what day but if this is a
product sorry how many days of
gestation are we going to have the female but it
is difficult
but sorry to do to be able to have
a number of females p  Breed at the same
time, for example, if we have come
from ten females with ten days of
gestation, then I have to use
the two terms that go back,
allowing us to have a number of
animals awarded at the same time,
then, as I told you, the
cycle lasts between four  and five
days and it has four
different phases that are projects within
our sme text and right-handed
if we can differentiate in which
phase of the century it is so strange are the
females that we are going to vary so
we are going to choose females that interest
us because it is convenient for us that they are  receptive
to be able to change a greater number of
lives in favor of this, which is the stage that
we should support and thus have
more chances that all of them will be
rewarded at the same time to detect
at what stage of the 20th century we are carrying out
by direct observation of the
genitals and to be more precise, of
course, a base psychology mania
what we are going to observe with the
observation  direct vation is the vulva with
vitality the blessing at the end in
terms of its vegetables the humidity and
dryness of the mucous membranes and the
final loss if there is a widening or
roughness
then here in these images
below I put them you can
download them slider in the  pdf that
we leave and you can see these links
that we are doing well in these photos
because of the truth, they are in the stages of saying it
and the changes that occur in
the parts of the scale, for example,
we are going to see that in the project and this is the
vaginal tissue  It will look more swollen
even frequently with grooves or
rough edges and a wide
final calculated
instead
when we are at the right-handed end
if you will see that the vaginal orifice is
closed and that there is no appearance of
many are around the building
They will also see you vaginally on my
journey and this makes the mucous membranes paler
than when we are 3-3
and how this system is better precise
as it requires par  to know more
precisely the stage of cycles such
a vaginal cytology can be done which
is really very simple what is done
is take a plastic shepherd extractor crosshead
with a little
saline solution very little a vaginal lavage is done
the centers there is the
pike  and it attacks again and in this
solution fiction or that we obtain
the ponytail while option without the need
for mined dyes and it depends on the type
of cells that we observe we will
know what it is in to say it is such is the
life in project we are going to use  bases that under
the microscope cells what he does in
our master are zero the epithelial cells
are compensated not
nucleated commonly called scales
then he brings me this the meta this we are going
to check it and many many
empty spaces and some leukocytes and very few
cells but very few  that it was
teamed, that is, very few of these scales
and the right-handed one will have great
captivity in quantity of leukocytes and
very few
Good nucleated regarding the monitoring of
the productions to give a
little of this management of the
colonies, three things are important,
mainly the
individual identification of the animals to be able
to deal with them and if we
keep animals that are not
producing  We are going to lose money and
we are going to bring inputs and we are going all the
time, so these things are very
important: individual identification
of the animals, the collection of data
and then the control of the data by the Egyptians,
which can indicate many
good things, such as  method of
identification clients there are many varied
there are some that are temporary that
I also put simply so that they
know when an experiment is done
perhaps short and there are few animals
lowered that they can use
temporary methods such as
marks with leo's mark or  with some dye but
to produce on a large scale, of course
, the methods are used  two of
permanent identification
good fields and as an example
microchip statues and in
and tall like these of the ears
I particularly like the theme of
the flies in the ears because they are the
device this is very cheap in order to
get instead that they are in
In our countries, regarding microchips
, it is still expensive for us or the
special tattoo artists that exist
for laboratory animals, rats and
mice, maybe they are quite
aggressive. Well, it depends on what each
one chooses. There are disadvantages and advantages
for each of these methods.
Identification also has to be
at the card level, for example, it is a
card for breeding cages where the
militarization of the card implies
the data of the parents, the date
of birth of the envy male, who is
the parents, the strain, the iu group of
power and on the date of the wall and
then down in the disputes meetings
that we have we have the arms of the
pups of the different c  beloved for each
line we are putting the data of
cartama 2 so when you enter this
which is an example with cages that
we have of anterior nerve we have to
have a card in the cage that
indicates what we have inside
the classrooms
with respect to
The minimum data collection that we have to have is a
copy of the cage cards
because every time we wanted to do the
others a reading of what we
have, we cannot be attacking
the wing cards, so
we have to have copies of these chests.
we have to have daily notebooks
to monitor the effectiveness and the
rigs match the births with the
data from the cameras from birth
to depreciation and we take care of this where
we will have the data of the 23 until
its sale or delivery to the investigator of the
referring destination
These records must be
controlled periodically so as
not to waste time and money, so these
records ah  Yes, we can get this
data, for example, the fertility that
we can take by
calculating how many pregnant females that
remain according to the gear, what
do the animals do, changes by females,
that is, the productivity of the
respected animals over the animals born
to see if we have any there, for example
problem between the birth of the
east and those of this one all for each female
we are to allow to know the colony
and each stage of which you of the
path that our colorina is doing
has allowed us to detect the problems
and look for strategies where we detect
our own or you seek benefits  to
continue improving production in
development,
well, finally, I think it is the last one,
we still psych
many of us in the system of we can, it is a
card, but the world is going towards
software for managing the economy,
so we have to start learning a
little about it.  this is to camps is where
example i put this ship software
because it is  taba but I gave as an example
because it is in Spanish and surely
we contact them they
can inform us in our language and
then in the seasoning software that
is not in Spanish but through their
website we can register it and he alone
for free like this  Good thing, all of
us will have to start
preaching and Orlando with the pleasure of
texting, software for colony management
that will surely help us a lot.
and so I am
willing to ask if someone wants to
ask a question
a farmer
here I have a question they ask me
surely maybe I download the pdf
that I said I had some more social
but if for a matter of time
I did not post them they ask me if there is data
regarding  As for the number of mice that
arouse per good year in 13 of the
es line, if they download it, the
presentation will go up.  n to achieve because
it had been put in South America,
no statistics are made
on the number of animals used,
but there are countries that do make
statistics, such as England,
Canada and, for example, the European Union
towards statistics of the reports and the
orography participate  20 and 27 countries,
sorry, they are very important numbers and
they were already with Enrique Soles, yes,
in the last report that was published
in December of last year, 2013, it was not
about the animals used in the
European Union in 2006
and this report told us that
Approximately 80 percent of the
animals used of the total number
of animals used in the
European Union were rats and mice rats
mice and rabbits approximately 60%
are mice and 14% were rats and
to talk to give a little to the
reality what this
percentage means in the european union if
we deal with the number of mothers who
seek that their relationship
smells extremely good  those of annual animals in huge in
toluca no sorry to speak
properly liked in 2012 10
million animals and 29 million
were rats mice and rabbits
in some aid
some
questions what do you think about doing it in
environmental growth with
hard plastic material  so that the faults when
he
well you will surely have seen
in the catalogs of the specialists in
environmental regrowth that sell you
and sell this type of material
ingredients in general I have not seen that they are
stolen
I was not referring to those that are tube types
or  If you are referring to something, especially
for the dumbbells, the
customers,
if something is received so that the animal
can have its teeth as if they were
the bones that good dogs have,
and it could be possible, studies should be carried
out, there are many people who dedicate themselves to
specifically study
environmental enrichment is that possibly if one
searches for studies said with this and well
there is what  and studying the subject
now he asks some other question he
says could from mexico they ask me if I
could remind you who makes the nests
that the males of the females in each
species
in rats and mice in the case
of mice in those bars the
behavior of a  cat and both
main to carry the material
towards the nest and if it makes the nest instead
in the rats the most possibly the one that
participates in the female and especially
when it is in three when it is well
rewarded or high in windows
if produced animals cannot be taken
from the explorer colony
as you suggest congratulate the
replacements of the founding colony the
inmates of the founding colony are
taken from the sale with the already founding ones
we have a line of animals and from the
line of animals we are going to take the
same replacements for that line
founder remember that these types of
lines are for their sibling seats
so we do not have to bring
any animals from outside the mis  mos and
not if the same couple that I have
mobile health pups or take out two brothers and I am going to
assemble the same gear
well from chile he asks me about manuel
if we believe that we are
prepared in latin america to
join research species it
is quite difficult because
The Latin American is like it
is quite hard to incorporate
new things but the new generations that
we come back have to
incorporate learning from the countries
that are going through a little in another
era there were not so many possibilities of
communication not so many possibilities of
biography or access to the  information and
then what we find is a
little more isolated than I would visit in the
rest of the world but with the facilities
we have now I have what it takes to be
able to go to Asia
and accept to work with new species
in research such as those
present in the  gas
good profile the best way to control or
prevent the blow that they ask me is
Good that we have seen Javier Hi
Javier,
the best way to find or prevent
smaller ones by
giving them more animals between
environmental growth because I will do it, he
said that although there are a lot of
articles on this and sometimes
even contradict with those that
contradict each other several  Opinions
on what causes the barber
is always associated with stress and the
movement of the animals so in the
end it is enrichment we are
preventing this from happening
and as I said in the presentation
once this type of
behavior appears it is very difficult to remove them
so it is  better time to prevent and
plan and plan an
environmental impediment
previously
they ask me here in it
martel asks me if I have seen
variations and the production of mice
in the offspring at different times of the
year
if really yes following they are annual
seasonal sometimes four  degrees in
some vines that maybe in
spring you  They have better productivity
in winter, maybe they will grow a bit,
but I also think that sometimes this
can be influenced because
the videos of many of the vivariums
that we have here in Latin America
unfortunately do not have
sufficient environmental conditions controlled
, so I think  that we should
worry about a variable that can
influence this that sometimes seasonally
we have some more variation
there is a
good one when the next
congress in the capital is going to hold you and how much it
is an Argentine resident
animal technology laboratories obviously that
this when it goes  to do it will be between the
22nd and 24th of feeling and of course
I invite you all to participate if
someone has information about him
about eating to write and
I will gladly provide it to you Juan Manuel
who is the product  I hope you can
come because you are very hysterical
and some more
when we leave
or they ask how many  crosses he was able to
maintain the strains of 57
and infinity until until
it can be maintained it can be done with
the 57 different crosses except for the
new ones in May well carolina I hope they
come with him
that we also come to the
congress of capitals in September or  of course I
'm going to be in May anyway
and some more
good I see more questions so I
thank you for the attention
I hope you enjoyed the talk